good morning Hank it's Friday special
Friday video well not that special
actually I don't want to raise your
expectations too much today's video
comes to you in five parts part one the
wall is as you have no doubt noticed
still there yes Hank the Great Wall fail
of 2009 continues to be both a wall and
a fail although I have made some
progress over there in the bottom corner
you can see the great white wall of cow
being ridden by the dread pirate
fireball Wilson Roberts then I wrote the
wall was a unicorn on the wall to try to
motivate me to bring it down because you
know I hate unicorns but even that
didn't work part to your song Hank your
song was incredibly good and I loved it
but it made me think about why we like
those crime shows even though they're so
predictable so when the Eddie and I
watch television which isn't that often
one of the things we like to do is watch
an episode of CSI and then immediately
follow it up with an episode of the
first 48 which is the show on A&E about
actual forensic experts and actual
detectives investigating actual crimes
because on CSI David Caruso has to like
out master the master serial killer and
has to like take off his glasses all the
time and say like I don't think you were
playing the marimba I think you were
playing the murderer in BA whereas on
the first 48 and in all real-life
murders the detective always has to end
up like holding the murderer as the
murderer balls because he feels so bad
about getting drunk and killing his
friend or whatever like CSI and all the
shows like it give you the delusion that
evil is some uncomplicated thing living
inside of certain people and not others
and I think we all deeply want to
believe the lie that evil is something
outside of us and we can be like hey
evil I got you in my screwdriver so
that's why I think we ultimately watch
these shows over and over again well
that and also I think our brains like
stories that make sense
and one of the main differences between
stories in real life and stories on TV
is that stories on TV makes sense anyway
great so I'm just wanted to say it made
me think about all that stuff part three
why don't we have any nerdfighters in
Antarctica I didn't say that right I
don't know Hank but this is a fixable
situation no dude awesome girl and
parcel mouth Kristina Horner wants to go
to Antarctica and all we need to do to
get her there is to vote for her in a
contest link in the sidebar
I don't want to get ahead of myself but
if we can get Christina to Antarctica
that could potentially mean that we
could have videotaped happy dances from
nerdfighters on all seven continents
part four Tom's Hank I have two things
to tell you about Tom's first Ming
master Tom is now officially the senior
executive nerdfighter he is the head of
all of the Ning and he's going to make
it much more awesome for everyone
because Hank you and I have been failing
so epically so everyone go to
nerdfighters comm it's about to get way
better although I think it is already
great and I want to say a special thank
you to all the Ning masters who have
made the Ning so awesome for the last
several months the other time I have to
tell you about is our original secret
brother Tom Hank I have great news about
secret brother Tom he is running for
office in the city of Cambridge
Massachusetts if you live in Cambridge
you should work for slash vote for him
link in the sidebar and more generally I
can't say how excited I am to see
nerdfighters seeking political office so
that we can push forward our political
agenda which is of course to mandate the
addition of in your pants to the end of
book titles and to increase funding for
the real valving of puppy-sized
elephants part 5 contest winners so I'm
giving away a copy of the paperback of
Paper Towns every day for the next two
weeks to my favorite ten word comment or
Paper Towns related video slash song I
just added that to the contest but if
you want to make a Paper Towns video or
song that would be so awesome Hank the
first three days of this contest has
actually seen four winners because I was
lying when I said I only had 14 books I
actually have more than that
the first winner is nerdfighter Astro
Graff who's 10 word comment was to end
his shame Willy requires a dose of by
wag rah the second winner is nerdfighter
Valerie 27 76 whose walk at summary of
Paper Towns was I'm in your minivans
peeing in your Blue Fin bottles stirred
Bell stir 24 who kind of made me tear up
a little when she said your books have
changed my life and I'm so grateful and
the fourth book so far goes to sensi
kitty who commented in eizan's words
admiration is the furthest thing from
understanding hey you'll see me on
Sunday but not before you see the new
outro